so Freunde herzlich willkommen vom Meer
und zwar werde ich ein bisschen was
erzählen was du demnächst ansteht es ist
ein großes großes Projekt geplant wenn
ich das größte Projekt ja es ist das
größte Projekt was jemals auf meinem
Kanal gab
absolut krankes Projekt geworden
[Musik]
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass das so
spannend ist und was war geil
hyped Bock Angriff
[Musik]
das hier ist Folge 1 einer 10-teiligen
Serie welche die Planung und Produktion
der zweiten Staffel 7er Strike begleitet
lass gern ein kostenloses Abo da um die
weiteren neuen Folgen nicht zu verpassen
um aber überhaupt verstehen zu können
wie wir hier hingekommen sind müssen wir
ganz vorne anfangen
wir sind Johannes und Max und wir sind
die Hauptverantwortlichen und
Produzenten für Seven vs white die Idee
für Sandros wild Camembert mehrere
Stationen über mehrere Jahre von von dem
ersten Brainstorming was man machen
könnte bis zu dem Zeitpunkt wo Fritz
seine Anfrage bekommen hat vom TV wo Sie
ihn haben wollten für eine survival
Sendung den ähnliches Konzept hatte und
wir haben dann zu Fritz gesagt pass auf
Fritz wir könnten das auch alles
selbstständig machen 100% Kontrolle
darüber wie es wird was wir wollen was
wir nicht wollen und dann eben ungemüst
auf Youtube und nicht fürs Fernsehen und
das haben wir dann gemacht und zwar
heißt das Projekt aktuell mal sehen ob
es bei dem Namen bleibt der Arbeit Ziele
aktuell seven vs wild wir haben uns
entschieden die erste Staffel zu
produzieren oder aber dann standen wir
vor der Frage wie setzen wir das um und
mit wem setzen wir das um dann lass mal
quatschen wie wir das machen und im
Endeffekt
ja war das wirklich eher so ein Ding mit
Kumpels und wen könnten wir einladen wen
kennen wir also das war halt wirklich
ein punkto gesagt haben wir wollen das
in einem Kreis drehen von Leuten die wir
persönlich einfach schon kennen das war
niemals so geplant als eine krasse
Produktion ob wir super super viele
Leute ran holen weil wir aber einfach
nicht die Cola hatten ne also es muss ja
auch vorstellen wir hatten super super
enges Budget und wir wussten quasi bis
es ausgestrahlt wurde nicht ob das Ganze
überhaupt funktioniert
[Musik]
wir sind ja eine Gang also wir machen ja
schon immer irgendwie zusammen geile
Scheiße wenn Fritz fragt erste Bock mal
7 Tage die auszusetzen sagt er ja klar
kein Problem wann und wo geht los ich
habe halt eine whatsapp-nachricht eine
Sprachnachricht von Fritz bekommen und
meinte so ja ich habe hier so eine Idee
und
Besuch da gerade nach Leuten hättest du
da Bock drauf so ein paar Freunde denken
sich so okay wir drehen mal wieder ein
Video mit Fritz okay diesmal bisschen
länger als 7 Tage Schweden let's go im
Endeffekt was dann so dass quasi das
Team wie auch die Teilnehmer hat aus
Freunden und Bekannten bestanden hat
weil wir halt wussten auf die können wir
bauen die sind zu dem Zeitpunkt an dem
Ort wo wir sie brauchen und die bringen
das know-home ist ein größeres Projekt
ja dann müssen alle an einem Strang
ziehen aber ich würde es hart feiern so
und dann nimmt man sich einfach mal dann
10 Tage Zeit fährt runter nach Schweden
macht ein kleines Basiscamp und dann
geht das da 7 Tage rein in die Wildnis
let's go Bommel schreibt gerade hier
schon er ist dabei naja ich finde die
Idee geil also der Entschluss steht wir
wollen das ganze produzieren und dann
ist natürlich die große Frage auch für
uns was kostet das denn überhaupt
natürlich kannst du sagen ja okay
braucht zwei GoPro ist aber auch jeder
das dass das dann sogar kommst du auf
irgendeine Summe die stimmt aber nie und
die stimmt bei weitem nicht egal was du
vorher kalkulierst es kommt immer Kosten
dazu die hast mich allen berechnet und
auf einmal liegst du 20 30 40 50 000 €
über dem was du kalkuliert hast dann
kann so viel schief gehen da dann
brauchst Du im Prinzip einen guten
fünfstelligen Puffer alleine damit du so
ein Projekt umsetzen kannst und damit
Euch genau das nicht passiert gibt es
finanzguru die freundlicherweise Sponsor
dieses Videos sind und es damit erst
möglich machen dass wir so ein riesen
Projekt umsetzen können der ist ein
digitaler finanzassistent die alle eure
Einnahmen und Ausgaben verteilt über
verschiedene kontentract ihr könnt alle
eure Konten eintragen und sogar scalable
capital oder andere Neo Broker
hinzufügen wodurch ihr diese dann direkt
mit in der Finanzübersicht habt ihr seht
was reinkommt ihr seht was rausgeht und
vor allem wohin wie viel rausgeht
außerdem seht ihr aber alle eure
laufenden Verträge in der App und können
diese dann direkt in der App recht
sicher kündigen und euch wird ein
Sparpotential angezeigt also der Betrag
mit dem am Ende des Monats zum Sparen
rechnen könnte das Ganze ist unheimlich
wichtig wenn sparen investieren oder
vielleicht so ein Projekt umsetzen wollt
dass ihr einfach wirklich vernünftige
Übersicht habt wie viel Geld euch
wirklich zur Verfügung steht und gerade
in der momentanen Zeit Stichwort
Heizkosten etc macht es natürlich mega
Sinn endlich mal ein vernünftigen
Überblick über seine Finanzen zu
erlangen um einfach besser planen zu
können über den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung und mit dem Code Dave
könnt ihr finanzguru Plus für ganze drei
Monate komplett kostenlos testen mit
finanzguru plus hast du zusätzlich zu
kostenlosen Grundversion noch weitere
Features wie Analysen smarte
budgetvorschläge oder das frei
verfügbare Einkommen zur Verfügung also
ladet euch die App herunter registriert
euch verknüpft eure Konten tragt den
Code Dave unter dem Reiter mehr ein und
erlangt so eine viel bessere Übersicht
über eure Finanzen und hier nochmal ein
riesen Dankeschön an finanzguru die mit
ihrer Unterstützung dieses Videos so ein
Projekt erst wirklich möglich machen wir
sind jetzt nicht neu in der Branche und
haben natürlich auch Rücksprache
gehalten mit einigen Leuten die
verschiedenste Projekte schon gemacht
haben gemeldet haben und alle haben
gesagt ey Jungs das könnt ihr nicht
bringen das könnt ihr nicht machen es
ist unverantwortlich da geht euch jemand
drauf ihr seid euer Leben lang
unglücklich macht's es gibt einen guten
Grund warum das noch niemand gemacht hat
ich bin
ja voller Rauch ich hatte jede Nacht
Sorge dass ich quasi eine Vergiftung
bekomme
das war schon
eine Aufgabe sag ich mal so alle
denkbaren
Szenarien sich zu überlegen was könnte
alles passieren und wenn dann trotzdem
etwas passiert was man auch bei
gründlicher Prüfung nicht hätte vorher
sein können ja dann ist das eben
Schicksal und die mussten sich selbst
darüber im Klaren sein worauf sie sich
eigentlich einließen übrigens was
dageblieben ist kannst du mal kurz
zeigen ist eine kleine Narbe ich glaube
durch unseren Kontakt zu den Outdoor
Youtubern haben wir so ein bisschen
dieses Gefühl von etwas echt machen und
sich wirklich durchbeißen und das nicht
zu faken weil der Weg ist zu faken ist
super super leicht also das deswegen ist
es auch fast alles survival Shows
gefaked fast alle Formate auf Youtube
sind irgendwie in irgendeiner Art und
Weise Skripte gefaked damit man das was
dabei rauskommt irgendwie vorhersagen
kann wir konstruieren eine ein Konstrukt
das schmeißen wir die Leute rein dann
wird gefilmt und das was passiert
passiert das war einfach gopros so
funktioniert der GoPro geht mal da raus
find mal was euch passiert und dann
gucken wir mal unser Anspruch war dann
eben auch weil wir diese Leute aus dem
Auto Bereich kennen die wirklich
rausgehen wirklich sich in extreme
Situation begeben dass auch eben in echt
zu machen das war unser Anspruch und das
haben wir auch gemacht
ausgesetzt in der Wildnis von Schweden
und kämpfen sieben Kandidaten 7 Tage ums
Überleben als ich davon abgedreht war
ist uns allen glaube ich ein riesiger
Stein vom Herzen gefallen die Freude war
groß bei den Teilnehmern die Euphorie
bei bei den ganzen Team es war schon
echt egal wir hatten sehr gutes Gefühl
das abgedreht hatten
max hatte ein sehr gutes Gefühl ich war
da so ein bisschen zugespalten weil ich
dann im Nachhinein hauptverantwortlich
war für den Schnitt des Ganzen und ich
wusste noch nicht so richtig
funktioniert das das Zusammensetzen also
ist die eine Sache wenn die Leute
erzählen ich habe coole Sachen gemacht
die andere Sache ist funktioniert das am
Ende im Schnitt wird das rund versteht
man das als Zuschauer haben die Leute
gut moderiert man kann im Prinzip sagen
wenn das ganze abgedreht ist dann ist
eigentlich so von der Arbeit vielleicht
ein Drittel gepackt das ist nicht so als
wäre das Ding dann fertig leider das ist
also du hast dann vielleicht ein Drittel
und dann beginnen wirklich Tage und
Wochen wo du dich durch kämpfst das ist
teilweise als würdest du deinen Honig
schwimmen weil das so zäh ist so lange
dauert teilweise sind die Folgen erst
fertig geworden am Tag der
Veröffentlichung und trotzdem waren die
Folgen bei weitem nicht perfekt johannes
hat sich einfach drei Monate
eingeschlossen der hat in einer ein ich
habe die Behausung gesehen das war
einfach nur ein Rechner Boxen alles
Molton also alles dunkel und da hat er
drin gesessen der war reif für die
Klapse danach aber er hat durchgezogen
ich kann mich noch sehr gut an dem
Moment erinnern als die erste Folge
online ging ich war gerade auf einer
Party und ich bin nicht von meinem Handy
weg gekommen ich habe die ganze Zeit
aktualisiert die ganze Zeit aktualisiert
wie sind die Echtzeit Aufrufe wie kommt
das an kommt das besser an als normales
Video das wäre schon mal Indikator und
tatsächlich also die die Klickzahl von
der ersten Folge die noch nicht so
gigantisch waren wie die anderen Folge
war schon bisschen Kinder darunter
gefallen weil ich sowas halt noch nie
gesehen habe wie ein Videos so krank
durch die Decke gehen kann und nicht nur
dieses sondern auch alle folgenden
Videos der Staffel gehen durch die Decke
durchschnittlich erreichen die Videos
4,8 Millionen Views und insgesamt wird
die erste 16-teilige Staffel mehr als 77
Millionen Mal auf Fritz Kanal geklickt
damit ist seven vs wild offiziell die
größte Creator Serienproduktion Europas
ohne das genau das jemals das Ziel war
das ganze so krass ja doch schon viral
geht und nicht nur eine Folge sondern
eine komplette Serie damit habe ich
definitiv nicht gerechnet dass das erste
ist so erfolgreich wird zweitens so viel
publik bekommt und so viel Zuspruch und
vor allen Dingen auch so viel Fans
hervorruft hätte ich niemals gedacht das
hat der Wellen geschlagen die ging ja
über Youtube hinaus meine Großeltern
angeguckt es hat einfach alles gebumst
so Staffel 1 hat sehr sehr gut
funktioniert viel viel besser als wir
erwartet haben und deswegen kann man
auch relativ zügig anfangen diesen
Jahres die Entscheidung okay wir wollen
die Staffel 2 und allen war klar wir
wollen auf einen anderen Kontinent wir
wollen extreme und ich glaube das haben
wir gefunden einfach mit Freunde the
pressures on ich mit dabei der will sich
das geben dann die Regeln natürlich ganz
Klar verschärft ne ich würde excited ich
bin dabei ich freue mich extrem es ist
jetzt nicht mehr das ist Schweden das
bekannteste Kandidaten dafür zwei
Übersicht junge es hat mir nicht alle
sieben Gegenstände dabei komplett anders
und ich glaube das kann man sagen
deutlich deutlich krasser